IT'S EMILY COMPAGNO.
PRESIDENT TRUMP VOWING TO SEND
AS MANY TROOPS "AS NECESSARY" TO
STOP A CARAVAN OF THOUSANDS
MARCHING TOWARDS THE
UNITED STATES IF THEY REACH THE
SOUTHERN BORDER.
THE PRESIDENT ALSO BLASTING
DEMOCRATS FOR THE PROBLEM.
>> President Trump: YOU KNOW
HOW THE CARAVAN STARTED?
I THINK THE DEMOCRATS HAD
SOMETHING TO DO WITH IT, AND NOW
THEY ARE SAYING I THINK WE MADE
A BIG MISTAKE.
THAT'S AN ASSAULT ON OUR
COUNTRY.
THAT'S AN ASSAULT.
AND IN THAT CARAVAN, YOU HAVE
SOME VERY BAD PEOPLE.
YES A VERY BAD PEOPLE.
AND WE CAN'T LET THAT HAPPEN TO
OUR COUNTRY.
>> Dana: TRUMP NOT BACKING
DOWN AFTER SAYING TERRORISTS IN
GANG MEMBERS MIGHT BE AMONG THE
MIGRANTS.
>> President Trump: I SPOKE TO
THEM LAST EVENING THE DAY
BEFORE.
I SPEAK TO THEM ALL THE TIME AND
THEY SAY, AND YOU KNOW THIS AS
WELL AS ANYBODY, OVER THE COURSE
OF THE YEAR, OVER THE COURSE OF
A NUMBER OF YEARS, THEY HAVE
INTERCEPTED MANY PEOPLE FROM THE
MIDDLE EAST.
THEY HAVE INTERCEPTED ISIS.
THEY HAVE INTERCEPTED ALL SORTS
OF PEOPLE.
THEY HAVE INTERCEPTED WONDERFUL
PEOPLE FROM THE MIDDLE EAST AND
THEY HAVE INTERCEPTED BAD ONES.
THEY HAVE --
>> Dana: PRESIDENT TRUMP
CONTINUING TO ANSWER QUESTIONS
FROM THE MEDIA.
I WANTED TO PLAY ONE MORE
SOUND BITE, SOMETHING YOU'RE NOT
GONNA BELIEVE ABOUT WHAT WAS
SAID ABOUT OUR MILITARY.
WATCH THIS.
>> IF YOU PUT MILITARY DOWN
THERE, WE KNOW WHAT THE GOD
FORBID IS IN THIS SITUATION.
HOW DOES THAT PLAY?
I WAS IT GOOD FOR ANYBODY?
YOU'RE NOT GOING TO TURN AWAY
THOUSANDS AND THOUSANDS OF
PEOPLE EVEN IF PEOPLE START
GETTING SHOT.
WHAT MESSAGE DOES THAT SEND?
WHO WINS?
>> Dana: DID SURPRISE ME A
LITTLE BIT HE WOULD SAY THAT
BECAUSE OUR MILITARY IS NOT
KNOWN FOR GOING AFTER INNOCENT
PEOPLE.
THEY ARE THERE TO TRY TO PROTECT
THE BORDER.
ANYWAY, GREG, WILL START WITH
YOU.
>> Greg: NOT VERY BRIGHT, THAT
CUOMO FOLLOW.
WASN'T A NICE THING TO SAY.
I WONDER ABOUT THE MEDIA BECAUSE
THEY TEND NOT TO ASK THE VERY
SPECIFIC QUESTIONS LIKE HOW DID
THE CARAVAN START?
WHO CALLED IT A CARAVAN?
HOW IS IT BEING MANAGED, WHERE
THE PEOPLE MANAGING IT?
THEY SAY THAT THE CARAVAN IS
BLOOMING LIKE IT IS SOME KIND OF
NATURAL EVENT OR THAT IS
SPONTANEOUS.
IT'S ACTUALLY QUITE ORGANIZED.
IT'S ORGANIZED BY MEXICAN
ADVOCACY GROUPS, AND THEN WHEN
YOU GET TO THE SIZABLE GROUP OF
PEOPLE IN WHICH YOU CAN'T TELL
WHO'S IN THE GROUP AND WHO ISN'T
WHICH IS WHY YOU NEED A PROCESS,
BECAUSE THERE COULD BE
TERRORISTS AND OBVIOUSLY THERE
COULD NOT BE TERRORISTS.
WHO'S GOING TO KNOW?
THE MEDIA TAKES THE NARRATIVE
AND THEY TWISTED, SO AFTER
HELPING THE ONSLAUGHT MULTIPLY,
THE ACCUSED TRUMP OF SEIZING IT
AS AN ISSUE WHEN BEFOREHAND, IT
WAS THE MEDIA AND THE ADVOCACY
GROUPS WHO HAD SEIZED ON THIS
SPECTACLE TO BEGIN WITH TO
CREATE AN UGLY POLITICAL ISSUE.
AND THEN THEY GO BUT LOOK WHAT
TRUMP IS DOING.
THEY ARE A BUNCH OF HYPOCRITES.
YOU KNOW IT IS SADDER?
AVENATTI IS TELLING THE
DEMOCRATS TO GROW A SPINE.
WHEN MICHAEL AVENATTI BECOMES
THE VOICE OF REASON FOR YOUR
PARTY, YOU ARE IN TROUBLE?
>> Dana: TALK ABOUT IN TERMS
OF THE MEDIA COVERAGE, SAYING
THAT THE MEDIA SHOULD NOT TAKE
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S WORDS AND USE
THEM SO THAT THE ONSLAUGHT WAS
TOO STRONG.
THEY THINK MAYBE THERE WAS
SOFTER LANGUAGE.
THEY ARE DOING HIS BIDDING.
>> Jesse: IT'S LIKE THE MOB
CONTROVERSY.
DON'T CALL IT A CARAVAN.
IT'S A PARADE, PROBABLY WHAT
THEY WOULD SAY.
THEY HAVE REPORTED BREATHLESSLY
ABOUT HOW MANY SCOOPS OF
ICE CREAM THIS PRESIDENT HAS,
AND THEY ARE NOT EVEN CURIOUS
ABOUT HOW THIS CARAVAN ARE
HAPPENING.
I THINK THE ONLY PEOPLE WHO'VE
SENT REPORTERS DOWN TO EMBEDDED
IN THE CARAVAN, FOX NEWS.
SARA CARTER DOWN THERE.
AND WILLIAM LA JEUNESSE.
"THE WASHINGTON POST" HAS
SOMEONE DOWN THERE, AND JUDICIAL
WATCH EVEN HAS SOMEONE DOWN
THERE.
THERE'S NOT A LOT OF INTEREST IN
THE MAINSTREAM MEDIA, SO WHEN
TRUMP SAYS SOMETHING ABOUT THE
CARAVAN, THERE IS NO WAY FOR
THEM TO FACT-CHECK IT.
THEY ARE GOING TO ASSUME THE
PRESIDENT IS SAYING INCORRECT
THINGS, AND SOME OF THE
REPORTING COMING OUT OF THERE IS
VERY INTERESTING.
80% OF THOSE PEOPLE IN THE
MIGRANT CARAVAN ARE MALES UNDER
THE AGE OF 35, AND THEY ARE NOT
FLEEING VIOLENCE.
THESE ARE ECONOMIC REFUGEES.
DO YOU KNOW THEY HOLD
"THE WASHINGTON POST"?
WHEN THEY GET THERE AND START
MAKING MONEY IN AMERICA, THEY
ARE GOING TO WIRE THE MONEY BACK
TO EL SALVADOR.
SOME OF THESE PEOPLE ARE GANG
AFFILIATED.
A LOT OF THESE PEOPLE HAVE BEEN
PREVIOUSLY DEPORTED, AND THAT'S
BEEN CONFIRMED.
IF THEY ARE REALLY THAT UPSET
ABOUT THE CONDITIONS IN THE
COUNTRY, INSTEAD OF MARCHING UP
NORTH TO AMERICA, MARCH AGAINST
YOUR OWN CORRUPT GOVERNMENT.
THAT WOULD SOLVE A LOT OF
PROBLEMS IN MY OPINION.
>> Dana: HERE, JUAN, WE ARE
TWO WEEKS AWAY FROM THE
MIDTERMS, TWO WEEKS TODAY.
SOMEONE LIKE JOE DONNELLY OR
CLAIRE McCASKILL, TWO RED
STATE DEMOCRATS RUNNING FOR
REELECTION, THEY KNOW THAT FOR
THE NEXT 13 DAYS, THE REPUBLICAN
CANDIDATES ARE GOING TO BE USING
THIS ISSUE AND IT'S NOT GOOD FOR
THEM IN THEIR CAMPAIGN.
>> Juan: NO, BECAUSE ANY TIME
USE FEARMONGERING, IT REALLY
PUSHES A BUTTON AND I THINK THE
PRESIDENT AND THE REPUBLICANS
RIGHT NOW, ABSENT A MESSAGE FOR
THE MIDTERMS MAY HAVE DECIDED
THIS IS THE BUTTON TO PUSH.
I READ TODAY STEPHEN KING, THE
HORROR BOOK WRITER SAID THE
REPUBLICAN CAMPAIGN THEME HERE
IS THE AFRAID.
THEREFORE, EVEN TODAY THE
PRESIDENT, WHO SUGGESTED GUESS
WHAT, THERE COULD BE
MIDDLE EASTERN TERRORISTS AMONG
THESE PEOPLE.
THEY ARE ALL GANG MEMBERS.
TODAY HE'S A WE DON'T HAVE PROOF
BUT THEY COULD BE.
THAT'S ALL HE DOES.
HE JUST PUSHES THE FEAR BUTTON
WHEN HE DOESN'T HAVE ANYTHING
ELSE TO SAY.
TO ME, WHAT'S INCREDIBLE IS, MY
REPUBLICAN FRIENDS BUY THIS
STALE BREAD OF HATRED.
THE PRESIDENT EVEN GOES HARDER.
HE SAYS I AM A NATIONALIST.
THESE GLOBALISTS WANT TO COME IN
HERE AND TAKE OVER.
NATIONALIST, WHERE WE'VE HEARD
THAT?
WHITE NATIONALIST.
STEVE BANNON, THAT WHOLE LINE.
SO HORRIBLE, SO INTENSELY
DIVISIVE.
OH, THESE BROWN HORDES.
>> Greg: DON'T YOU THINK IT'S
DIVISIVE TO SAY YOUR REPUBLICANS
-- YOUR SONS ARE REPUBLICANS.
YOU'RE CALLING THEM RACIST.
>> Juan: I'M CALLING THIS
ACTION BY THIS PRESIDENT, GIVEN
THE DIVISIVE NATURE.
>> Dana: SHOULD WE JUST DO
NOTHING?
>> Juan: HOW DID AMERICA REACT
BACK THEN?
IN TERMS OF COME YOU THINK ABOUT
THE JEWISH EXODUS, IRISH PEOPLE
COMING TO THIS COUNTRY AS A
RESULT OF FAMINE.
EVERY MOMENT, THERE WERE PEOPLE
IN THE FAR RIGHT TOO REACTIVE.
STOP THOSE JEWS FROM COMING IN
HERE.
WHY?
>> Dana: EMILY, DO YOU THINK
IT'S COMPARABLE?
>> Emily: KNOW, AND I WANT TO
POINT OUT TWO THINGS.
NUMBER ONE, THIS HUMANITARIAN
CRISIS PREEXISTED THIS CARAVAN
INTO ME THE MIXED MESSAGING AND
HYPOCRISY'S POINT FROM THE LEFT
WHO ARE IGNORING THE FACT THAT
16 JOURNALISTS WERE KILLED THIS
YEAR ALONE IN MEXICO, AND ALL OF
THE ATTENTION IS ON KHASHOGGI.
OR THAT MIGRANTS FOUND DEAD IN
TEXAS BECAUSE OF THE CHOKE HOLD
THE CARTELS HAVE ON NOT ONLY
THOSE GOVERNMENTS SOUTH OF US
BUT ALSO THOSE PEOPLE, INCLUDING
THE FACT THAT AN ENTIRE POLICE
OFFICE WAS ARRESTED FOR
CORRUPTION.
THE BORDER SECURITY IS A SMALL
PORTION OF THE ABSOLUTE CRISIS
IS GOING ON, AND THE
HUMANITARIAN CRISIS IS BECAUSE
OF THE POROUS BORDER AND LACK OF
LAWS THAT WE HAVE.
SECONDLY, ABOUT THE MILITARY AND
THE COMMENTS.
YOU HAVE TO UNDERSTAND THE
NATIONAL GUARD COMES UNDER STATE
AUTHORITY WITH FEDERAL FUNDS.
THE PRESIDENT CAN FEDERALIZE
THEM.
ACTIVE-DUTY MILITARY, THE
EXCEPTION TO THE POST, TOSS --
SUPPORT, NOT LAW ENFORCEMENT
LAW ENFORCEMENT.
THE HYPERBOLE FROM THE LEFT,
SAYING THAT THEY ARE GOING TO
START SHOOTING PEOPLE IS
OFFENSIVE AND TOTALLY INCORRECT.
>> Juan: WE DISAGREE,
OBVIOUSLY.
I FEEL SO PASSIONATELY ABOUT IT.
THIS IS LOWBALL POLITICS.
SOMETHING INSIDE, SO IMPORTANT.
THE HUMANITARIAN CRISIS PREDATES
THIS.
PEOPLE SHOULD THINK OF IT IN
THOSE TERMS, BECAUSE I THINK THE
CONSERVATIVES HISTORICALLY HAVE
BEEN EMPATHETIC, COMPASSIONATE
PEOPLE, NOT LIKE WITH THIS
PRESIDENT IS DOING.
>> Jesse: I HAVE TO ADDRESS
SOME OF THE THINGS YOU SAID.
SARA CARTER, WANTED HER CALLING
SARAH FOX NEWS, WENT THERE.
YOU ARE NOT THERE.
SHE'S THERE.
SHE'S A COLLEAGUE.
SPOKE TO GUATEMALAN INTELLIGENCE
AND INTERVIEW PEOPLE IN THE
CARAVAN AND IS CONFIRMED THERE
IS MS-13 AFFILIATED GANG MEMBERS
AMONG THEM CARAVAN.
IF YOU ARE GOING TO SIT THERE
AND CALL YOUR COLLEAGUE A LIAR
WHILE YOU ARE SITTING IN THIS
NICE AIR-CONDITIONED STUDIO IN
MANHATTAN, I THINK IT'S
UNBECOMING.
SECOND OF ALL, YOU HAVE NOT
SAID --
WHAT ARE YOU GOING TO DO BUT THE
CARAVAN, JUAN?
YOU HAVE NO PLAN TO DO ANYTHING
ABOUT IT.
DO YOU HAVE ANYTHING TO OUT OF
SUBSTANCE TO WHAT TO DO WITH
THIS 7,000 STRONG MIGRATION
COMING NORTH?
WHAT ARE YOU GOING TO DO?
>> Juan: I THINK IT'S VERY
CLEAR, GIVEN REPUBLICANS CONTROL
THE WHITE HOUSE --
>> Jesse: WHAT ARE YOU GOING
TO DO WITH THE BORDER?
>> Juan: WHY DON'T THEY THINK
THE IMMIGRATION SYSTEM THAT IS
SO BADLY BROKEN.
>> Jesse: FIX THE IMMIGRATION
SYSTEM?
IT'S BECAUSE OF DEMOCRATIC
POLITICS.
THE FEINSTEIN MEMO.
THIS IS WHAT ATTRACTS THESE
PEOPLE.
>> Juan: THIS IS LOWBALL
POLITICS AND YOU ARE ON MESSAGE
FOR PRESIDENT TRUMP.
TODAY HE SAID HE HAS NO PROOF.
>> Jesse: YOU WANT TO PROTECT
ELECTION INTEGRITY BUT YOU DON'T
WANT TO PROTECT THE INTEGRITY OF
THE BORDER.
IF THESE WERE RUSSIANS COMING
ACROSS, YOU WILL PROBABLY BUILD
THE WALL.
>> Juan: PEOPLE COMING WITH
GUNS, HORDES, THEY'RE GOING TO
TAKE OVER AMERICA?
>> Jesse: NO ONE IS TAKING
OVER ANYTHING.
>> Greg: ACCORDING TO JUAN'S
MESSAGE, MEXICO IS RACIST TOO.
THEY ARE TRYING TO STOP
IMMIGRANTS OF THEIR BORDER.
EVERYBODY IS RACIST IF THEY
DON'T AGREE WITH YOU.
YOUR FILTER IS NOTHING BUT RACE.
>> Juan: I THINK YOU HAVE A
DIFFICULTY ACKNOWLEDGING WHERE
THERE IS RACIAL INJUSTICE AND